at what point do you switch from this as
purely a defensive like treasury
strategy of we want to take the cash on
our balance sheet and put it in an asset
that uh we can protect ourselves protect
our purchasing power to then it feels
like you made the switch to go offensive
that first bond offering was an
offensive i think you called her right
there i think that it's a defensive
strategy uh through the dutch auction we
had to do the dutch auction to provide a
graceful transition for our shareholders
to get long bitcoin
right you're either long bitcoin or
you're selling out to us at a premium
one of the other and then from that
point bitcoin started moving up and our
stocks started moving up and then we
realized that we
like the conservative thing to do is
just stop there and if we'd stopped
there i mean we would be
all equity 475 million dollars invested
at a
11 000 a coin or something and that's
not a bad result right we would have
made 6x our money
but um what we realized is we could
borrow money at 75 basis points and we
and
you know bitcoins up 171 percent a year
every year for a decade right
if you can borrow money at one percent
and invested 171 percent your arbitrage
is 170 on how much well how how much do
you want right like where are you going
to stop that when you borrowed at the 75
basis points i was impressed but then
you followed it up and you borrowed even
more at a zero percent interest rate if
i remember correctly
what was the second offering because the
first offering came out the strike was
398 bitcoin kept moving up our stock
kept moving up
eventually that bond was the best
performing bond of the entire year
right anthony what i'm saying is of
every single corporate bond sold in the
year 2020 every convert
every junk bond everything sold every
municipal bond whatever you could
imagine the single best performing bond
was microstrategy convertible bond which
where you would have you could have
doubled your money you know at some
point is trading insane amounts like
triple
you know your money on a bond okay so we
had good success there and of course
bitcoin kept moving up
and our stock up moving up and
we realized by february that we could do
another offering the next offering uh
was we came in the market offering 600
million dollars the first one we started
with 400 million this time we started
600 million but again it was
oversubscribed we upsized it exercised
the green shoe it became a 1 billion 50
million offering
and the range was 50 basis points to
zero so we struck it as zero
and uh
you know uh up 50 37 i forget the number
but we ended up having a 50 premium
or 47 percent i forget exactly it was a
high premium it was a low coupon the
strike price was 1432 a share so now put
this in perspective this is 10 times
the price of the dutch auction
[Music]
you know some number of months earlier
now um
so why'd we do that well because if you
could borrow a billion dollars at zero
percent interest and invested in
something going up 170 percent a year
pretty good trading why wouldn't you do
it right uh like every single business
on earth that's debt financed presumably
is borrowing money to invest in
something which is going to return a
higher yield than the cost of the debt
now this i want to pause here and make
one point
the reason that i was sensitive to
inflation
like
was
i immediately
saw the inflation in march and april in
the stock market
right because my inflation bogey wasn't
if i were to go to all my uh investors
and say i got 500 million dollars i'm
investing in a 2 interest and inflation
rates 1
they wouldn't have given me a pat on the
back they would have said the s p index
is moving up 10 a year your bur your
hurdle rate your cost to capital is not
one percent or two percent it's 10
and maybe you're getting five percent
yield on uh on a piece of debt then i
hold my nose but you're losing five
percent a year
half-life of the money is 12 years
okay fine but like you shouldn't be
holding you should be you should be
buying your stock back or buying another
company with that sitting on that cash
is
it doesn't make any sense
safety says the dollar weighted
monetary inflation rate across you know
all all currencies
for the last 30 years is 14
interesting number he comes up with 14
is the inflation rate of
the currencies now that would be the
inflation rate on scarce desirable
assets or any portfolio of assets and if
i look at my screen right now over the
last 10 years the s p 500 is showing
14.15 percent interest a 14.15
compounded annual growth rate
nasdaq's up you know whatever 19
you know gold is up
20 basis points
nothing bitcoin's up 170 base
170 percent right and long bonds give
you like two and a half percent
so the monetary inflation rate equals
the s p index well you the the
traditional way you'd value
a stock
is
you would put a risk premium on it
and you would say
well your cost of capital is the return
plus the risk premium so
it used to be we think well there's a
three percent risk premium and the
inflation rate then would be 11
but i think that if you buy the s p
index you're kind of in theory stripping
out the risk because you're buying 500
companies
so the s p index can be viewed as a
proxy for monetary inflation
and
the question of inflation is what's your
inflation rate well what do you need to
buy
if you're a consumer
then your inflation rate might be cpi if
you agree to buy what the federal
reserve tells you you should want
right and and the market basket of
things in the cpi is what the government
says you should want in your life but
they never included a picasso or a jet
or a yacht or a house in miami beach
in that market basket